welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the mandalorian chapter 13
set in stone so much about the star wars
universe making it a much
richer world with very exciting
narrative priorities
all kinds of reveals including the
child's name as grogu
in his backstory at the jedi temple on
coruscant ahsoka tano
alive and well in all the rebels glory
and a possible upcoming link with the
pre-retired luke skywalker but for me
the most important detail was
this moment where is your master where
is grand admiral thrawn
whoa [ __ ] we have got to talk about who
thrawn is
because assuming dave baloney and john
favreau are playing this right and by
all evidence they appear to be bringing
thrawn into the mix represents the
mandalorian series leaping forward from
a period piece filling in the gaps in
the timeline to a
wild card space fantasy whose future
would be impossible to predict
one that doesn't have to thematically
rhyme with itself every three movies
so thrawn was introduced in timothy
zhan's star wars novel heir to the
empire in 1991
as a grand admiral of the imperial navy
tasked with
carrying on the empire after the
emperor's fall
inspired by figures like alexander the
great irwin rommel sherlock holmes
thrawn's
ruthlessness and cunning especially
compared to the many other
incompetent imperial officers made him a
beloved character
arguably responsible for the whole
popularity of the expanded universe and
so it's a big deal that he's back
because much of the expanded universe
has since been discarded
and overwritten sadly but throughout all
of that thrawn has been one of the
few characters lucasfilm has clung to
refusing to alter significantly
because he is that good so good that he
has since been
brought into canon with season three of
star wars rebels and various graphic
novels canonically
thrawn is a chiss going by many names
including
mithra nurodo born kivu rao nuru
but his lovers call him vuron naked he
comes from the planet rentor
in the unknown regions who's an officer
in the chis ascendancy during the clone
wars before it was inducted into the
empire thrawn actually crossed paths
with anakin skywalker during this period
helping him rescue padme and then he was
recruited as an imperial officer
as a fierce hand-to-hand combatant he
began as a low-level weapons officer but
then worked his way
up to the rank of grand admiral a rare
title in the empire
during the galactic civil war his skill
at empathizing with his enemies to
exploit their weaknesses
made him a fearsome enemy to the crew of
the ghost
which is what we saw in his arc in
rebels and that is how dave felony is
now tying him into the mandalorian see
on rebels thrawn was last seen
disappearing into hyperspace
alongside ezra bridger via hyperspace
whales
and then in the finale of rebels we saw
ahsoka tano and sabine wren
both setting off in search of ezra with
thrawn now presumably being
a key part of that search if you find
thrawn you know where ezra went but now
we're learning that since then thrawn
has apparently stayed
busy this episode of the mandalorian
taught us that he has
morgan ellsbeth serving him plundering
worlds like this forest planet of corvus
harvesting natural resources in order to
build a starfleet that is how ahsoka is
now trying to get it thrawn
now tell me where is your master where
is grand admiral thrawn now you could
infer from this that
ahsoka is still on that search and we
might be seeing a live action sabine
wren and ezra bridger very soon
though interesting to note that sabine
ren is not with
ahsoka right now so what happened well
you could say thrawn might have already
killed ezra and sabine but assuming dave
filoni wants to deliver fanservice to
all of his rebels fans i doubt he would
kill off these beloved characters
off-screen
and lead them to that unceremonious fate
ezra and sabine might not be as big of
the characters as
like ahsoka but they're still roughly on
the same level as say bogatan
and she got to survive so i'm assuming
they're still alive too also worth
noting that in the rise of skywalker rey
did hear the voice of ahsoka tano among
the
jedi voices it was then voiced by
animated series voice actor ashley
eckstein
suggesting ahsoka might have died
sometime in these 25 or so years in
order to be a
ghost voice but in that cacophony we did
not hear the voice of ezra bridger
taylor gray in there so he is probably
still alive at that point and probably
still alive at this point thrawn might
just have ezra and sabine imprisoned and
ahsoka is now trying to free them but
beyond this short term mission
introducing thrawn and the live action
has even bigger implications for how
filoni and babro are expanding this
whole universe and if you watch this
episode closely some overlooked details
do
start to reveal that secret but before
we continue i want to thank hellofresh
for sponsoring this video
you can get mouth-watering seasonal
recipes and fresh pre-measured
ingredients delivered right to your door
with hellofresh it's america's number
one meal kit hellofresh makes cooking at
home fun easy and
affordable look i am not much of a chef
the best eggs i know how to serve are of
the easter egg variety hello fresh makes
cooking
so simple with their step-by-step
recipes and pre-measured ingredients
that even a dining
dunce like me can pump out some
delicious food
they cut the stress of meal planning and
prepping so that you can get dinner on
the table in just about 30
minutes or even 20 minutes with their
quick and easy options it's flexible to
fit your lifestyle
you can easily change your delivery days
or your food preferences
skip a week whenever you need i mean
just look at this idiot go
time for yum yums their meals are really
delicious with more
five star rated recipes than any other
meal kit service
just go to hellofresh.com and use my
code of new rockstars 90 to get
90 off including free shipping on your
first box
that's code newrockstars90 at
hellofresh.com
to get 90 off including free shipping on
your first box
okay so what exactly happened to thrawn
after his disappearance in rebels well
regardless of where he disappeared to on
the other side of that hyperspace jump
thrawn must have been missing
during the battle of endor that was a
true make-or-break moment for the empire
and if he was still commanding the
chimera he
at least would have been president for
that battle or present for the battle of
jakku the last stand for the empire
before
its transformation into the first order
decades later it's believed that his
knowledge of the unknown regions might
have helped
guide the first order in their formation
but really thrawn's absence from these
events
likely mean that most of his legends
narrative from timothy zahn's novels
could get overwritten
but this does position thrawn to be in a
far
more flexible narrative position going
forward because thrawn's whole identity
is based on a
disdain for the management capabilities
shown by other imperial officers
the guy's a rogue as a younger chiss he
joined the empire because he saw an
opportunity to rise upon a wave that
would inevitably flood the galaxy
and he wanted to be on the victorious
side of history but then after that
he kind of becomes his own man or chiss
so
while we have die hard imperial
loyalists like moth gideon representing
the threat of the empire on this series
i doubt thrawn would represent the same
thing it'd be redundant and a true
missed opportunity to explore what truly
makes
thrawn tick also notice how in this
episode ahsoka refers to thrawn as
elizabeth's
master where is your master where is
your master
that is an oddly specific way to define
elsmith's relationship
with grand admiral thrawn she didn't say
your leader or
your admiral or your commander gone are
those military ranks and
in their place master a more intimate
mentor echoing kind of the terminology
of the jedi or the sith furthermore the
slower kendo inspired fight choreography
shown by morgan ellsbeth using that
bescar spear as a bow
this echoes thrawn's melee skills as a
younger weapons officer
not the 4d chess naval mastermind
working for imperial goals
but one channeling his pre-empire chiss
ascendancy expertise
and then yeah finally that best car
spear a weapon specifically tailored to
bend off the strikes of a lightsaber the
lightsaber being
the weapon of a jedi or a sith or some
other poser i believe that all of these
clues are telling us something about
thrawn's plan
to oppose the lingering factions of the
empire
and to build his own fleet either a
restored
chiss ascendency or his own order of
thrawn
because elle smith and her soldiers are
not imperial they are not stormtroopers
there's no imperial insignia whatsoever
so they're not the empire but they are
mowing down forced planets to build a
fleet which is what elsbeth was good at
during the clone wars so what are they
building if not
a new rival fleet i believe thrawn and
ellsmith wanted her to carry that best
scar spirit not to
hunt her to kill jedi like ahsoka tano
ahsoka seems on her own personal warpath
disrupting elsbeth's bigger starfleet
plan but maybe elsevid has it to protect
herself from
either the new republic jedi luke
skywalker leia organa
or darksaber wielding imperial leader
moth gideon so this would make thrawn
and elsmath neither new republic nor
empire nor
first order but another less defined and
potentially
deadlier threat a variable wild card
force that hits both sides like
the boltons or omar or jack sparrow the
best characters
a force that could rise up after
palpatine's final order is destroyed
that is how great fantasy world building
works people it's not just a battle
between good and evil but we also get to
meet all the clever unpredictable
game changers that tip the scales
between these forces let me know what
you think thrawn's plan is
and you can support new rock stars by
checking out all the great options on
our official merch store new
rockstarsmerch.com
we got this shirt we got a high american
boss shirt we got a this is a white
shirt and
hot off the prices we got a new grogu
shirt check it all out because today is
the last day of our black friday to
cyber monday sale 10
off of everything in the store check it
out also subscribe to this channel hit
that notification bell follow me on
instagram
ea boss follow me rockstars thank you
for watching i have spoken
[Music]
you